two centimeters ladies
it's not really a bulge as much as a
tent effect right it's like an audi
belly button
your d
yeah yeah
no oh yeah
you did that on another show i did do
that you've taken your ticket old go-to
is it do i look comfortable let's be
comfortable i want to be comfortable on
your show i don't know how to look as
comfortable as you
is it
is that something from your show huh huh
i do feel more comfortable i do feel
more comfortable too how's your body my
body sucks man why
i like that we just stopped doing that
yeah we're not committing
we we just cgi aziz ansari over me and
posts and the ratings were right through
the roof
great to be here pete great to be here
man
you're like oh this got way better
cgi disease over i can't do these
without doing the this point
it's also my ross perot whoa vote for me
it's also the same thing very relevant
very true
yeah how am i doing you know you know
late night that wasn't great is it okay
really oh thanks i really am you know
i'm the first fan of the show i do know
that i really i've been i've been
emailing you you have to send you a
linkedin request
i did get that is that flatter bubbly
it's a bunch of bourbon in here
no it's um
it's flat cause i thought i'm like yo
mama oh
i'm talking eight cups my man
i'm sorry i don't know where that guy
your mom
has huge breasts
your mom is very well endowed thank you
you know uh i love him she's right
behind me isn't she i love goop i love
she's right behind me i love that joke
as a thing that's my thing i also love
your mama jokes yeah i love the one yo
yo
yo yo mama's so ugly people break into
her house just to close the shades
that is a fantastic pretty rude that's a
fantastic
the thought of someone being like
how am i gonna stop this they break in
there's valuables everywhere they're
like leave it leave it
finally a respite from seeing her face
this this isn't a yo mama joke but
there's um just a funny answer close
your legs your breath stinks whoa which
is like you have to think about it for a
second then you're like what what even
i'm not even sure i get it yeah
i barely get i barely speak english it's
my first life
your dad is uh is where's your dad from
and it's from haiti haiti
my dad is so bummed because i was like
on conan and i was like oh my dad just
found out what a computer is and he's
like tell conan i got my medical
doctorate
oh yeah let me text conan dad i didn't
go through eight years of med school to
make you a sale i just got out of the
boat
i can't do my dad you're like is your
dad simba from the lion king i can't do
my dad's voice it's insulting
it's
somehow racist when i do right now
we're the same race that's how bad the
impression is yeah it's it's hard to do
that it's a it's a hard you have to
commit is what i'm saying i can do oh
his name translated as where my keys
take
you know not a lot of people making
kunta
very relevant kunta kinte perot we gotta
we know what the kids like
you gotta let them know whose show it is
man i will burn this thing down